suivez moi je vous ouvre les portes de
la commune de peu sa villeneuve petite
commune de 550 habitants du puy de dôme
situé au pied des volcans d'auvergne son
école arc en ciel son château son mini
re et son art mural c'est l'autre avant
si le mini red hat et de plusieurs
milliers d'années
l'art mural est plus récent beaucoup
plus récent le 3 novembre 2015 la
population du village a augmenté de
pratiquement 10% en accueillant 48
migrants issus de la jungle de calais et
s'ils ont vu ses rentrées dans la cour
du château
ce n'est pas parce que son gps était
déréglé
mais tout simplement parce que je les ai
invités en septembre 2015
le gouvernement lance un appel à toutes
les communes en france pour accueillir
pour que les communes volontaires
puissent accueillir des réfugiés syriens
des familles et à ce moment là je me
porte volontaire comme une trentaine de
communes du département sur 500 que
compte ce département en octobre la
situation à calais devient critique
le gouvernement décide de créer décès en
centre d'accueil et d'orientation
temporaire pour les immigrants qui sont
à calais et qui souhaitent demander
l'asile en france le 26 octobre et 18
heures je reçois un coup de fil du sous
préfet qui me dit monsieur le maire est
ce que vous êtes prêts à accueillir 100
migrants je dis oui
avec quelques interrogations est ce que
nos locaux sont adaptés est ce que nous
serons prêts et la population la
population n'est pas informée
durant cinq jours nous allons nous
organiser avec l'association qui va être
choisi pour cet accueil
les services de l'état les employés
communaux va vérifier la mise aux normes
le chauffage en hiver aidera préparer
les lits est au fond la logistique c'est
pas le plus compliqué à gérer plus
compliqué c'est l'urgence et le maire
que je suis ne décide pas seul il en
conseil municipal jeudi réunit une
semaine pile après le coup de fil du
sous préfet et là ils disent oui
heureusement ça me rassure parce que
quelques heures plus tôt j'ai eu
confirmation que le bus arrivait le
lendemain j'avais profité en même temps
quand même pour informer la population
et j'ai distribué un communiqué dans
toutes les boîtes le 3 novembre à 20h30
à peu près le bus entre dans la cour du
château en décembre 48 migrants pour les
accueillir
je suis là avec le préfet on leur serait
bienvenue en français en anglais ces
jeunes un peu plus compliqué et un arabe
heureusement il y avait un traducteur
mais il y avait aussi le journaliste
beaucoup de journalistes et le lendemain
la petite commune de 500 habitants fait
la une de toute la presse régionale
écrite télévisés et à partir de là la
haine se déchaînent sakho
d'abord par des coups de fil 1 2 3 10 50
ingérable tellement que je suis obligé
de fermer le standard de la mairie puis
viendront les les menaces qui vont
arriver par les réseaux sociaux les
sites internet où je vais même être
condamné à mort suivront les lettres
anonymes
les tags on les a vus et c'est dans ce
climat que je vais faire la réunion
publique
trois jours après l'arrivée des migrants
il ya une telle attention à ce moment là
que la préfecture décidé de me mettre
sous protection policière
moi le petit maire de la petite commune
de 500 habitants
j'ai mis un beau costume je visais
blanche lundi à mes adjoints si jamais
je prends des coups au moins ça se verra
et je rentre dans la salle
j'étais plutôt dans le rôle du matador
qui rentrait dans l'arène mais très vite
j'ai vu que c'était moi qui aurait le
rôle du taureau ce soir la salle est
archicomble isation par tous dedans
dehors et les gens que j'ai en face de
moi je les connais je connais tous
est-ce que je vais entendre c'est
impressionnant ce terrible on n'en veut
pas de ces gens là ne sont pas comme
nous c'est pas à nous de les accueillir
ils vont tout détruire ils vont volcan
brio les nos maisons ont brûlé le
château y aura des détritus partout ils
vont violer nos enfants monsieur le
maire ils vont violer mes enfants me
crie cette mère de famille que je
connais très bien que je croyais bien
connaître ces violences est
impressionnant et puis au milieu de la
salle une jeune femme lève le doigt et
pose une question comment vont-ils jaffe
répéter pour que tout le monde entende
bien puis la laine s'arrête
comment vont-ils enfin la première
question qui va s'intéresser aux gens à
ces jeunes gens ces jeunes hommes cette
jeune femme que l'on a accueilli qui
sont arrivés après
perdu dénutri et la reine s'arrête de
brailler quand l'institutrice du village
propose de donner des cours de français
et à partir de là dès le lendemain
voilà la réunion se se finit des gens
viennent me voir spontanément en
proposant leur aide
mais dès le lendemain par dizaines les
bénévoles ils sont arrivés on a compté
jusqu'à 60
on nous aider pour leur apprendre le
français pour les véhicules et pour les
parties administratives et les amener à
leur visite médicale pour ramasser les
feuilles du château qui sont allés à la
piscine
ils ont découvert notre très bon
patrimoine ça marche et ça ça commençait
à bien fonctionner le cerveau a pu
fonctionner normalement
le principe du seo c'est d'accueillir
dignement et humainement mais c'est
aussi les retaper physiquement parce
qu'ils sont vraiment arrivé très fatigué
et puis les orienter les orienter et
notamment vers les cada les centres
d'accueil de demandeurs d'asile
et c'est ainsi que le site a pu une
vingtaine ont pu être orientés
on a pu griller en deuxième but ce
deuxième but si l'arrivée mois de
janvier alors là je veux dire quasiment
dans l'indifférence générale
ça veut dire que les médias étaient
passés sans doute à autre chose les
choses marrantes à signaler c'est que
cet indice en arriver les nouveaux bains
les anciennes de recueillir les
applaudissant et les tous les bénévoles
étaient là aussi pour faire le lien la
vie de la commune a pu continuer
normalement
les enfants sont toujours allés à
l'école le père noël est même passé les
voir
il était sage sans doute les
associations ont fonctionné la commune a
continué à fonctionner le bulletin
municipal qu'on a sorti par le cert du
cio et c'est normal mais il parle aussi
de la station d'épuration qu'on a pu
réaliser durant l'hiver a fonctionné
parce qu on a continué à travailler avec
eux au milieu d'eux ça fonctionnait
passe
en fait ça ça marche ça marche parce que
au fond la solidarité c'est silencieux
mais c'est terriblement efficace et
mobilisateur ça marchait parce que la
haine au fond c'est que du bruit quand
on arrête d'écouter ce bruit on se pose
juste la question qui vaut le comment
vont-ils au moment où mohamed mahmoud
ali mairie et dans quelques temps dans
trois semaines
nous organisons une grande fête des
retrouvailles avec les bénévoles qui
vont aller chercher les migrants qui
sont restés dans la région
et là on a hâte de les retrouver en hâte
de se retrouver
on hâte de les accueillir on a de nous
accueillir
et comme comme un parent comme un frère
comme un ami comme un enfant qu'on n'a
pas vu depuis longtemps
on veut juste savoir comme un niveau
merci
[Applaudissements]